okay welcome everyone welcome to the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and area studies at Yale
my name is Alex Deb's and I'm an
associate professor here in the
political science department and
normally Ian Shapiro the director of the
mechanoid Center would be introducing
the speaker today but unfortunately
teaching at this moment at least he
can't be here any senses regrets what
happening with you but thank you thank
you I'm happy to be filling in for him
and we're delighted to host Christopher
Andrus this year's Henry L Stimson
lecturer Christopher Andrew is an
emeritus professor of modern and
contemporary history at the University
of Cambridge he's the founder of the
Cambridge intelligence seminar and
founding co-editor of intelligence and
national security he's also chair of the
British intelligence study group and
former official historian of the British
security service mi5
he's honorary professor at Queen's
University Belfast and former visiting
professor at Harvard University the
University of Toronto and the University
of Canberra professor Andrews latest
book the secret world a history of
intelligence analyzes the period from
Moses to Putin and it's the basis for
his lectures this week his previous
books on the use and abuse of
intelligence including the sword and the
shield the world was going our way and
defend the realm have appeared on
bestseller lists on four continents
professor andrew is here to give three
lectures on the lost history of global
intelligence and why it matters today is
the first of the three and it's titled
how the lead role in strategic
intelligence passed from Asia to the
West the next lecture will be tomorrow
and it's titled a strange history of
American British intelligence relations
from George Washington to Donald J Trump
and then the third lecture will be on
Thursday and it will be entitled Russian
intelligence operations and the web
from the tsar nicholas ii to vladimir
putin and i hope you will join us again
for both of them the lord on 4 maps of
professor andrew will speak for about an
hour and then we'll have a Q&A for 30
minutes so i please ask you to reserve
your questions until the Q&A period and
when this is when we're done with the
Q&A around 6:00 there will be a
reception in the common room just behind
you let me add the funding for the
lecture series comes from an anonymous
donor in honor of Henry L Stimson Yale
College 1889 an attorney and statement
whose government service culminated with
his tenure as Secretary of War during
World War two since 1988 the Macmillan
Center and Yale University Press have
collaborated to bring distinguished
diplomats and foreign policy experts to
the center to lecture under books that
are published by the Yale Press without
further ado please join me in welcoming
Christopher angel let me begin by saying
modern honor it is to be giving the
Henry L Stimson lectures for many
reasons which include the fact that he
had access to a more extraordinary set
of secrets over an unprecedented period
than anybody else just about that I can
think of in the history of the United
States so it began in his junior year at
Yale when he was in Skull and Bones and
it didn't even quite end at the end of
the Second World War but he was involved
in the most terrible single decision
ever taken by any world government the
decision to explode the world's first
atomic bomb so to have the privilege of
talking about some of his secrets and
what he did with them is something that
I highly appreciate so what's the third
thing I think to note is about him the
way that he dealt with his extraordinary
secret I think the first thing is that
he changed his mind about these secrets
more than any really major figure in
American history who
ever had access to secrets of this
importance so in his diplomatic career
he becomes Secretary of State under the
Hoover administration the public
administration because in 1929 he's
confronted with the kind of intelligence
which shortens the second world war even
though people argue about how much it
shortened the the second world war
SIGINT as it was called at the time in
other words the intelligence derived
from intercepting and when necessary
decrypting other people's communication
what was his attitude to that it was
entirely unethical and he insisted that
the State Department stop it and it did
and he closed down the black chamber not
the official name but that's what most
people told him and yet when he comes
back as Secretary of War under the
Roosevelt administration at the
beginning of the Second World War
what is he enough for as much SIGINT as
possible what his diaries which are in
the so it's telling library say that the
most exciting thing that had ever
happened to him whilst the Japanese
SIGINT at the beginning of them the
Second World War so here we are this is
what his library his Diaries as in
sterling library he recalled wonderful
progress were made by us codebreakers
quote I can't even go in my diary go
into some of the things that they have
done well what couldn't he go into the
main thing that he could not go into was
these success or in breaking the
Japanese diplomatic cipher which the
Americans were not the Japanese called
purple that of course produced an
immediate interdepartmental problem the
army wanted sole responsibility for the
diplomatic code you know they accepted
that the Navy should be able to break if
they could which he couldn't at that
point their naval codes and vice versa
so what was agreed forgive me for
putting it like this but the silliest in
tight departmental agreement
in the entire history of the United
States and that is a challenge which I'd
be really excited it was somebody can
think of a West example so this is the
official formula it was agreed after
lengthy negotiations that the Army and
Navy would exchange all diplomatic
traffic from there into facilities so
when they got these coded messages
they're passing on to the other the army
receive all purple traffic of days with
an even date two four six eight and so
on and the Navy all traffic of days we
then odd date one three five seven nine
not a very good idea I'm sorry so why
did they do this
well you know the just about the oldest
platitude about learning from the the
past and by the way the only way that
platitudes get to be platitudes is by
being true the about the oldest
platitude is only those who understand
past mistakes and can learn from them
and those who don't are doomed to repeat
them so had the history of intelligence
people know this idiotic agreement would
have been absolutely impossible because
the Stimson and the FDR administration
would have known that the French tried
this a complete chaos
the British had tried to complete chaos
the Russians have tried it and even
worse chaos and the idea that they would
have done it again
no not even plausible and cause what it
course was chaos in the White House as
well I mean the the military and the
naval a has found it too difficult to
swap responsibilities for this every
other day so they did it every other
month and there's General Edwin Park
Watson FDR's military aide but also a
close friend who was so confused by the
odd to even date Sigmund at 30 starts
filing somebody's waste paper basket and
he's denied access altogether in July
1941 and there's the the naval aide who
could tell the difference between odd
numbers and even numbers and so he
becomes the sole supplier now what does
this produce I mean as usual in history
conspiracy theories get from our
attention the simple human incompetence
but we all know from our professional
lives that when something goes badly
wrong it is usually because people have
been incompetent rather than they've
thought of a really interesting
conspiracy so here we are sadly to the
6th of December 1941 the Navy makes the
original intercept and to its immense
annoyance 6 is an even date so it has to
hand it over to the army and it does
hand it over to the army but the army
has no money on Saturdays to get people
in the afternoon so they have to hand it
to back and then the army does get some
money and evening so they cooperate for
the first time and all the detail of
this by the way I think is so
well-established and so many official
reports it's simply that the sheer
incompetence of Saturday the 6th of
December hasn't attracted a fraction of
the attention of the non-existent
conspiracies of the the sane huh
it was the first person to really notice
this this man
Sherman Kent Yale historian founder of
CIA a cold war intelligence assessment
and also involved in that in the OSS in
World War two and he's the first person
to articulate the proposition that there
is no future for American intelligence
unless it learns from the past and in
particular learns from the errors of the
past that's what he says and by the way
the way the school for intelligence
analysis at CIA headquarters where I
will be speaking on this American tour
is named in his honor
so here's my experience but I think it
extends to both sides of the Atlantic
because this extraordinary intelligence
headquarters whose mere existence was
kept secret for thirty years after the
Second World War but is now the first
British intelligence headquarters to
become a tourist site Bletchley Park and
the scene of the greatest intelligence
collaboration between two powers since
there were different numbers of powers
so beginning my career in Cambridge
Christ some years ago because the people
who are recruited to Bletchley Park were
very young I say we'll talk to them
about daily experience I was fascinated
by what they knew but in the end I think
I was also the first person to be
fascinated by what they didn't know now
they they brilliant young academics from
all kinds of disciplines
some of them historians political
scientists and so on it didn't occur to
any of them by which I mean not a single
one that the extraordinary achievements
of Bletchley Park had been equalled by
previous British codebreakers and
terrible moments of national crisis so
three times in the last 500 years
Britain has faced invasion from forces
greater than its own it thought it was
about to be invaded by Hitler in 1940 it
wasn't but it was a sensible idea that
Hitler certainly wanted to but those who
broke into his codes and the slightest
idea that their early 19th century
predecessors had broken Napoleon ciphers
during the Peninsular war and as who you
bring to Britain as imagine everybody
has you can see the marked hello towers
that were put up all around the south
coast in order to protect us against an
invasion which didn't happen I love
myself time for that and that's the
breaking of the code which you can find
in if you have time in the British
National Archives and the people who
broke napoleon ciphers and the slightest
idea
the during the the previous main
invasion threat and leave out by the way
the Glorious Revolution because King
Billy William of Orange was invited in
so there doesn't care no philip ii of
Spain the Spanish Armada of 1588
well philip ii ciphers were broken just
as a few hundred years later Napoleon's
were and a few hundred years hundred and
fifty years after after that Hitler's
were so you know because SIGINT sounds a
very modern
the idea that Franklin Delano Roosevelt
understood it better than Queen
Elizabeth the first is it's a common
idea even though nobody had actually he
was
nearly as good as Queen Elizabeth first
I'm not saying he wasn't better than
Queen Elizabeth the first in a number of
areas he was but not when it came to
code breaking so there we are
and the all the detail of how the
ciphers were broken by Elizabeth's of
his code breaker whose name is
pronounced Holland Thomas Phillips but
he was rather dyslexic so it's called
Felipe's haven't gone toe would know
what is a start here is a Code Breaker
in the 1580s who is personally
complimented by the Queen herself he
would not believe in how good part the
Queen accepteth of your service
she awarded him repent FDR didn't do
that absolutely anybody during the
longest presidency in the history of the
United States I'm lifetime to talk about
six days of this but so now we move on
to something which I hope apart from
being historical significant will also
be helpful during your next visit to
Venice just about everybody here has
been to Venice and if you haven't well
there's plenty of time and here are a
few things to look at which the guides
won't tell you so when does Europe begin
to get really good at SIGINT and take
the lead from Asia at the beginning of
the Renaissance and it has the most
beautiful intelligence headquarters in
the history of intelligence the United
States has never sought to compete and
for the most beautiful intelligence and
headquarters so and there we are here's
what you get shown anyway and here's
what you will only get shown if you ask
to see so this is where the Council of
ten talked about all the official
secrets and then if you know you have to
ask to see this the secular inquisitors
who were supposed to be responsible for
state security they could have anybody
they wanted to paint the fresco
so they got Tintoretto the prodigal son
on these ceilings I have been to a most
American intelligent list of quarters
I've yet to say sorry I don't want to be
in the middle in visalia stories written
the level of artistic patronage is
pathetic sorry I'm Clifford
and then they've still got around there
just a couple of the blaze dweeb or how
do you denounce a traitor in 16th
century Venice there's a special letter
book look at this fellow where his his
mouth is that's where you put the letter
denouncing people now I'm against that
but the artistic quality is and far
higher than the FBI have every reason
thought about but this is where you
really have to ask what is most original
in this extraordinary building it's the
world they're Europe's first SIGINT
agency which is on the top floor and so
there are these cramped rooms which it
divided laterally into two which means
that in some of their appalling because
you can only open the windows of you
have access to the both floors at the
same time and there's something about
code breakers I mean they're they're
very they're very modest in their
requirements so here is the best code
breaking organization in history of the
world until that point Bletchley Park
and they put in missing hearts and you
know when the United States somewhat
later has far more you know if there is
an ugly I'm sorry if I mustn't get
carried away if there is an uglier
intelligence headquarters in the entire
history of intelligence headquarters I
would be jolly surprised and I do not
expect I do not expect to be surprised
now i'ma go time for him haven't got
time for him but what's extraordinary is
that the Venetians who think that they
are well ahead particularly of anything
that the Ottomans could do it's complete
nonsense their major theoretical
breakthrough is exactly the same has
been as had been made by the Baghdad
House of Wisdom in the the ninth century
and here's a man because there's no like
a real likeness al-kindi and this is his
crucial text but the problem from the
point of view of Islam is that from the
moment that the Ottomans become the main
Muslim power from the moment that they
take constant level they can't be doing
with all this so they throw
his stuff away and it has not discovered
again till 1987 my book contains details
which library to look at if you won't
have a look at the the original and of
course there's also absolutely no idea
that Mohammed on both of the basically
evidence that I'm about to summarize had
a far better grasp of intelligence then
any secular over that mountain on
secular European leader in the Middle
Ages so this book the sealed nectar is
the best-selling Muslim biography of
Muhammad and it describes him as as as
to the others the greatest military
leader in the entire wealth which for
the non faithful is obviously debatable
but according to the conventional
version he fights twenty-seven battles
he instigates about fifty armed raids
playing clothes at Ellen in attention to
military intelligence
now you don't find that in Quran
obviously but because the Quran is about
the message not the messenger but if you
look in the hadith which record his
deeds and saying there is more
intelligence there than you will find in
any medieval text about a Western leader
so all these needs paying some attention
to but nowadays they're badly only
people who pay attention to it are the
Islamists so here is a typical al-qaeda
training manual which you find on the
web if you want to the Prophet Allah
bless him and keep him had a local
informants in Mecca who told him
everything big and small that my harm
the Muslims welfare right well the
problem is the Ottoman Empire the
Ottoman Empire is a great power the
greatest matter is Mediterranean power
but it despises in intellectual
innovation so after their conquest of
continental Constantinople the Ottomans
refused to allow an Arabic printing
press until the end of the 18th century
they refused to establish embassies
permanent embassies abroad which are the
basis for Western espionage so they're
doomed to
decline and Venice takes over why Venice
well because it has the biggest trading
empire of the Middle Ages and it needs
political as well as commercial
intelligence in order to keep that no
time to talk about that and they what's
next well the the age of discovery now
obviously impossible take all the detail
in there but the arrows give you some
sense of how importance it was so all
one's going to do is to compare European
maps of the 16th century with Asian maps
to see why Europe has now overtaken Asia
so this is a very well known map you can
find it on the web the salviati's world
map at 1525 notice how quickly the
Western image of the world has changed
it shows the new world coastline which
had only been discovered since now
Columbus is first voyage in 1492 and it
also indicates which is really important
the awareness that just don't know or
what the rest of the world consists of
so China the first map in China which
shows any part of the world at all is
1602
that's not produced by a Chinese
cartographer it's produced by a Western
Jesuit missionary so here's the best
known early bit of European imperialism
Spanish conquest of the new world which
is a classic example of using
intelligence as a force multiplier
against a civilization which doesn't
even understand it plenty all the things
that did understand but not that so here
is Fernando Cortez now the odds
unbelievably great that people argue
about whether the Aztecs I don't a how
many hundreds of thousands of men they
had put up against him what is not in
doubt is that Cortes has only six
hundred men with him but they beat this
huge and sophisticated empire in two
years and how do they do it they do it
our intelligence so there's Cortez and
La Malinche who was a young slave woman
who had an extraordinary gift for
languages indeed an extraordinary
intellectual gifts anyway
and they're meeting the man I pronounced
as Montezuma but it's I should be able
to develop that but what I can't so what
she is telling him all the time is that
Montezuma is beatable why because most
of his vassals and all of his rivals
absolutely hate him
so in the end the six hundred people
because they are able to get an alliance
against him it's not as simple as that
of course but that is an essential part
in the force multiplier
now here is the of the absolute role
model so Francis Walsingham Elizabeth
the First's intelligence chief and at
the time as possible to combine these
two roles and it wouldn't be nowadays
the Queen sees wells in them every day
so he is able to control the whole
SIGINT humint and all the other
intercept IVA love myself tandem engine
and the other thing it's absolutely
essential if you're an intelligence
chief that you dare to tell your
political and superiors what they don't
want to know so what one of Margaret
Thatcher's intelligence chief said at
one point was my job was to tell the
Prime Minister what she did not want to
know and that is why ultimately Putin's
intelligence is a mess the idea of
anybody risking their future by telling
him what he doesn't want to know is you
know the more autocratic you go to the
regime the more impossible that is now
we know there's one occasion in which
wells even tells the other Queen
something she doesn't want to know
she took her slipper off threw it at him
and got a direct hit but that didn't
stop me you're a moment which is to the
inestimable credit sorry about being
patriotic really near the British
intelligence no haven't got time to talk
about him no not them there was not time
for them either
that's very interesting I wish they
would time talk about that now one of
them one of the great things about
looking at the influence that in tempted
sister had over the ages is how diverse
the evidence is now one of the few
things in the can scarcely bring myself
to pronounce the terrible B word brexit
there I've done it once and will not do
it again but the few areas in which
Britain still leads the world is royal
dresses I mean if there has been a
program on American television services
which has had higher viewer ratings than
the last couple of royal weddings I
would be surprised but I am used to
being surprised I might have got that
wrong now
what nobody has noticed about Queen
Elizabeth of firsts but her dresses is
that they would make important political
points now this is the last portrait
over not later than 1602 she died in
1603 you could not do a portrait of her
unless it was exactly as she wanted so
the first thing that you notice look at
the fair she is 29 and 3/4 and it's been
twenty nine and three quarters for the
last half century or almost that but
this dress is boasting about the fact
that she has the best intelligence
service anywhere and you can tell that
from the symbols you can't see the
symbols of that scale but you can now so
what does this mean don't even think
about it traitors my boys and it was not
an equal-opportunity profession at the
time my boys can see everything you do
and hear everything you say the eyes and
ears and when mi5 was founded in 1909 it
took one of her eyes and that became its
symbol as well yes well what tells me
forgotten now I mean people if rulers
are not
fascinated as most of them aren't but
quite a few of them have been the view
tends to be oh no problem
oh yes there was a problem I mean the
nearest thing that Britain has to a
national celebration and is going on at
this very moment is that Guy Fawkes Day
when the Pope used to be burnt I mean
just as simple as a boat on actual
Pope's and Guy Fawkes it was the chief
from Plata I mean it's the silliest
national celebration in in modern
history and it makes me really proud to
be a Brit because you know just one
shouldn't take it too seriously so
there's Guy Fawkes who's the third from
the right and called Guiteau Forks just
to make him that bits much more
interesting so because there is this
extraordinary idea as I've begun to say
that Coe breaking concern is something
that only really clever people with
amazing maths degrees in the 20th and
21st century do the fact that it was
sometimes more important at the 16th or
17th century is something that deserves
more attention that it's so far received
and I haven't got time to talk about
this yes I have so another at Cambridge
codebreaker John Wallace who was one of
the founders of the Royal Society the
main scientific society in British
history and during the English Civil War
the only time we were as you know ends
with the only time we've actually came
to the monarch he breaks Charles the
First's ciphers chance' first used them
in order to communicate with his french
wife who had understandably fled abroad
and this is probably no I I think I did
locates where it's not in the Stirling
library but kind of snows amazing now is
so Parliament the Roundheads
the first Republicans in British history
in order to discredit the king D publish
he's decrypted correspondence and it
tends to be forgotten that early British
Republicans were extraordinarily
anti-feminist and so one of the ways
that they use against him is the
argument that he's not merely bossed
around by his wife but worse than that
it's a French wife and even worse than a
French wife it's a French Catholic life
like the rare the Royalists were not
quite as anti-feminist
the Kings councils are wholly managed by
the Queen though she be of the weaker
sex born an alien bred up in a contrary
religion yet nothing great or small is
transacted without her privity who
consumed the Queen appears to have been
as harsh and imperious towards the king
and she is implacable to a religion
nation in government so that's an end to
her and him and as a reward for this
John Wallace is made professor of called
geometry potato chili was mathematics at
Oxford at the age of only 33 and he'd
like the job so much he kept him for
more than half a century now the same is
true in French history great code
breakers were more esteemed at the
beginning of the 17th century than they
have in any century including so far as
I know at the 21st so here is a
carbonara Schiller who liked himself so
much he insisted that there were three
different pictures of him on the same
portrait and there's his code breaker on
there on the right all plan ha seen
y'all ha seen y'all is a very
appropriate name because not merely it
does if it referred to the nightingale
but it's also French out go for a key
that will pick any lock and he is so
appreciated that he is bought a chateau
this Chateau the chateau de do easy now
the Chateau GZ is now in a degraded form
the Hotel de Ville at which is only 20
miles from Paris but when he was there
louis xiii went to see him and say how
wonderful it was louis xiv went to see
him in the beginning of his reign and so
did assertive costed alicia yeah now at
no point in American or French history
since has any codebreaker been shown
that level of personal esteem so no
American president even goes to
code-breaking headquarters until a
Ronald Reagan in 1986
actually had to get there because he had
absent mindedly quotes quoted some
highly classified they intercepted
communications from Colonel Gaddafi but
there we are that was all for all
forgiven so at the end of the 17th
century and again just to imagine this
in British or American or French history
at the end of the twentieth sharp arrow
of the Academy font-size which had been
founded during the century produces a
book on the 40 most illustrious lipra
zena's Frenchman of the 17th century and
he includes somewhere near the top it's
a great Code Breaker so you know it's a
we just don't understand it seems to be
the background for all this now back to
back to Asia what tends to be forgotten
about British intelligence is that for a
period about a couple of hundred years
it was actually more active in Asia then
it was in Europe there's obvious reason
for that and the obvious reason is that
Britain is in the process of conquering
India and we tend now adays to think of
outsourcing and intelligence as
something that is 20th century complete
rubbish
there has never been a moment when
Britain out sourced as much intelligence
in the 20th of the 21st century as it
did in the 18th and 19th so here is a
harry's of recent book on the conclusion
possibly slightly overstated the authors
appoint East India Company imagine a
company with the influence of Google or
Amazon granted a state sanction of
monopoly and the right to levy taxes
abroad and with mi6 British foreign
intelligence and the army at its
disposal so there we are the East India
Company official with escort foot
soldiers and Indian retainers what you
don't see are the intelligence officers
but the single best least so regarded in
Britain certainly Britain's leading
historian of India in recent years so
Christopher Bailey he reaches the
conclusion the British conquered India
in under two generations not only
because of military superiority but
because
they used a sophisticated intelligence
system and you know if there's a turning
point of the 18th century it's the
Battle of Plassey and Clive of India
says exactly the same so from the moment
one starts looking at the outsourcing
it's extraordinary
this is the coat of arms of the British
East India Company 1803 by which time
the East India Company has a private
army of 260 thousand which is I think
something like four times the current
British army three anyway and was twice
the size of the then British Army and it
has boy intelligence personnel well the
government outsourcing has yet to even
come close to getting what it was a
couple of hundred years ago and there's
the Duke of Wellington it never even
occurs to Napoleon that his main cipher
had been broken by Wellington's
intelligence staff during the Peninsular
war and that was the beginning of the
end for Napoleon but where did he learn
the importance of military intelligence
not in Europe he leant it against the
martyrs in in India so Victorian
intelligence operations were on a much
larger scale in India than Britain this
is what I was brought up to call
Calcutta Kolkata nowadays and there is
Queen Victoria lording it over the
Indians with the assistance of one or
two pigeons who are impertinently so
what all this then has is an influence
on how intelligence develops in and some
of the things that on both sides of the
Atlantic we take per absolutely granted
in the operations of intelligence
without many place things fingerprinting
for example that was devised in British
India in order to work on Indians and
then it was discovered that it also
worked on Brits and then the Americans
discovered it also worked on Americans
but all this was developed by Herschel
who was a magistrate in India and those
are some of the very early ones that he
took in
in 59 and 60 so if you go through
British intelligence the 19th and the
first half of the 20th century what you
see is that some of the the best
practitioners had actually learnt that
trade in India including this man Sir
David Petrie who was director-general
hearing and i5s finest hours the double
cross system in World War two his whole
previous career have been in
intelligence in India and what
historians the British Empire only just
beginning to discover is that even after
independence the local intelligence
services quite often not telling their
governments wish to keep in touch with
the British so here's something I found
in the mi5 archives 1957 Maliki didn't
have to say this in my talks and
discussions I never felt I was dealing
with any organization which was not my
own besides this hospitality and
kindness which all of you showed me it
was also quite over whelming so when I
think of the exciting things about
looking at the intelligence dimension
which is of course just as I mentioned
it is not it cannot be never will be the
whole of human history but the mere idea
of doing Gender Studies for example
without giving a really important role
to intelligence is something I find
really a bit baffling so here's the
breaking the public breaking of the
glass ceiling in Britain the first woman
to become a head of any of the world's
major intelligence agencies is this
woman and I've been fortunate to do into
the on it Stella Rimington
now this goes back to the First World
War and it's an interesting example of
how you can arrive at what I think is
fair to say is a famous conclusion
starting from entirely different
premises so at the beginning of the
First World War
mi5 is very small because all
able-bodied men are supposed to be off
fighting and so it's only the non
able-bodied and so the gents when
they're sitting around one evening
actually arrive at and this is pretty
much what they did arrive at why don't
we have the cleverest say
or trees in British history not
difficult because people were not
offering women interesting jobs so mi5
approaches two of the Oxford women's
colleges Royal Holloway which was the
Women's College then in Oxford and the
Cheltenham ladies College which was best
in private school for but now what you
what you then get then is the first
organization in British history and I
would dare to say American history open
to in which a high proportion of the
women are not simply better educated but
actually come from higher up the social
scale because for a woman to go to
university in Britain before the First
World War meant that they had to come
from pretty high up the social scale now
what's the response of the men to this
the men's response some really dislike
the fact that their secretaries are
cleverer than they are others a really
grateful that their secretaries can
actually understand the accounts which
they can't so it's is broadly speaking
positive but this is a cartoon that was
done during the First World War which
shows what I think than everyday scenes
so you you see a smart 20 year old
something-year-old and secretary
explaining to her boss who's twice her
age and whose molecule has gone astray
what a document actually means and as
you can see he doesn't really know how
to respond to that so what you get as
some extraordinary karez number
extraordinaire
Jane sis for married name later
Archie she comes straight from school in
1916 ten years later she is accepted as
mi5 s leading Soviet expert the leading
Soviet expert in in Britain and British
intelligence and she qualifies with
support from mi5 as a barrister in 1924
thirty years before that would have been
an impossible profession in anywhere in
Britain and then also an another area
this is not intend to be too frivolous
but just looking at the greetings cards
sent by official bodies in Britain you
can arrive at I think really rather
large conclusions now it may seem silly
to devote so much effort to producing a
new year and card but they did and in
the bottom left hand corner you can see
well you might be able to see the
initials of the man who designs it eh w
Eric Holt Wilson in vain it designed and
then in the bottom right hand corner
there's by I'm sure who was the most
expensive illustrator of the time now
what's going on and very few other
people on the 1st of January 1918 dared
to predict that this would be the last
year of the war
mi5 mi roman 5 does so and what you see
as ella Li 5 s image is now female it's
a female masked britannia how do we know
that beneath the mask is awry v easy
look at the end of her Trident and you
can see its em i ro Minh 5 and what
she's doing is impaling the loathsome
figure of subversion which was always
male and always impossibly her suit
there was no such thing as clean-shaven
subversives in those days at least seven
so it was it was believed and then if
one looks at the parties now you know
it's up to you to draw your own
conclusions and these invitations but
these were the raciest invitations sent
anywhere again in british officialdom
and they were drawn up by both men and
women and as you can see this young mi5
female operative has borrowed her boss's
cap and she is a little notebook which
says mi5 so there's now we now move to
the most interesting archive i have
recently found in the university of
oxford
I come from Cambridge we know there is
interesting stuff there but we don't go
there all that
so this is the most attractive
intelligence headquarters in British
history it wasn't designed for
intelligence but his Blenheim Palace
it's where Churchill was born you can go
there you probably already been there so
the majority of the personnel they won't
have course allowed the best jobs but
the majority of personnel were female
but there wasn't there weren't enough
bedrooms there so they were lodged at
Keeble College Oxford and they had such
a good time that cable College wrote to
mi5 to complain that their dinner
parties was simply outrageously
boisterous well you may not be able to
see everything there so I'll read a
little bit for you in comparing our
staff with undergraduates and sound
anyway mi5 insists they couldn't
possibly have broken all this crockery
it is difficult to envisage that among
other things our staff a broken 28 large
coffee pots 740 plates of all sorts 104
dishes of sorts in the dining room and
less than has been a free fight and so
on so it's always been an exciting in
British intelligence point that I want
to make is that cable College was coming
in complaining that for women it was
actually too exciting being in British
intelligence to say well we're
outrageous but that's the kind of thing
that Oxford colleges say well they don't
actually very often so thanks chief
leader the level cross system based
mainly on double agents who feed this
information to the enemy World War two
is mi5 s finest are so far now back to
what they didn't know you know the only
in the the 20th century
the fact that you know I can't pronounce
this I do forgive me as some say is the
best that I can do actually if I weren't
here I would probably say something zoo
but anyway contemporary of and of
Confucius required reading at West Point
and lots of other places in the in the
United in the in the United States
all warfare
based on deception I don't think there's
much doubt that the double-cross system
was partly but only partly based on the
teachings of Santa and you know here is
an area in which it takes the West to
millennia to catch up with some of the
key work of the Confucian era whose the
man who does it it's the first head of
mi5 why is it the first rate of mi5
because of Vernon Cal who had been in
China during the Boxer Rebellion and the
beginning of the of the century is a
qualified Chinese interpreter and
probably I think I would say almost
certainly the first Western intelligence
office to read the art of war and also
the first to recruit double agents in
World War one in order to yes but I'll
go home for a little bit longer but what
I think has been lost sight of on this
side of the Atlantic is that two most
successful First World War double agents
were both Americans the first is a good
example of one of the things that
historians complain about in Britain but
the intelligence services still regard
is extremely important if you tell
somebody that if they become your agent
you will never never even their
grandchildren and great-grandchildren
will not know then I mean that's
extremely frustrating for her story
there's a good argument against it
but you're far more likely to get good
agents if you do that and I have
certainly come across examples of people
whose confidence in British intelligence
derives largely from their ability to
keep very old secrets indeed so when I
was official historian of mi5 I saw the
Como file I know who it was and I'm not
going to say and I with anybody else and
there's a good argument that I showed
that I'm not Rosslyn Batok he rather
liked being it so we know who and we
know his name
so you get over to Alania later and he
really pretty unusual in human history
that something really important's only
has its importance acknowledged
other continents after all that time so
here's Allen Dallas head of the CIA
director of Central Intelligence used to
be called sons Oh deserves credit not
only for the first remarkable analysis
of the ways of espionage but also for
the first written recommendations
regarding any organized intelligence
service and there's a Kissinger who
concludes that Mars foreign policy owed
more Towson's than to Lenin it's quite
good evidence that I'd the regionís and
therefore can't possibly say it's
conclusive but during the long march Mao
did actually send for a copy of the art
of war that is known and an ironic
moment in Chinese American relations
when who Jintao comes over in 2006 he
presents george w bush with a super copy
of the art of war by Sun sir and it's
that one I know because it's in the bush
library now and I am ready to try that
well I'm ready so then you get this
extraordinary period in which sons are
actually becomes part of a US celebrity
culture this one you can still get
although I don't recommend it on that
premise of how other timeless strategies
of sansa can transform your game at
likely story but Don Wade is and allows
of that then something for women on the
left some sort of the art of war for
managers and then the real evidence of
celebrity culture Paris Paris Hilton and
of course nowadays this is the the last
Indian National Security Adviser he says
and I don't believe him that the Indian
Alfa Shastra was equally important what
it does have is more about ways of
assassinating people and any other book
I've ever so but men and his argument
goes like this many Indians believe
Orientalist caricatures of India India
supposedly incoherence to strategic
approach is actually a colonial
construct as is the idea of Indians
somehow forgetting their own history and
needing the beard taught by Westerners
as they're there now my visit I'm sorry
to and on such a personal moment my
visit to the strange
named a university in the world and the
Strand it's named University of the
world is Peking University Beijing
because they wish to be recognized as
the oldest one now Beijing 1 2 234 or
whatever it is I had a really good time
there and you know we couldn't talk
about the present but the fact that
students all knew about summer and could
apply to it doesn't tell you I found
rather interesting but of course China
is nowhere near at the same level now as
it was in Confucius's time because from
the moment that you can't talk about
crucial things it's really not worth
talking about so I have this isn't the
best book that I've ever read on China
but it's the one with most arresting
title I think the People's Republic of
amnesia so if in China you attempt to do
research which combines nine six one
nine eight nine you can't do it because
that is the date of Tiananmen Square
people talk about whistleblowers in the
West but if he any whistleblower in the
West is added to our knowledge nearly as
much as those who release the tournament
papers so we're now back to Yale the man
who got it most right and take continues
getting more right than many people who
write about intelligence issue in Kent
whatever the complex puzzles we strive
to solve whatever sophisticated
techniques we use there can never be a
time when the thoughtful person can be
supplanted as the intelligence device
Zhu cream right on Sherman Kent 6070
years on he is still the best thank you
very much
I would be very happy to answer or
trying to answer better say try to
answer the questions
Thanks okay talk
here's to know when you start making the
distinction yes the the contemporary
distinction goes back to the founding of
both organizations which is in in 1909
now so far as operation operating abroad
the rule at the time when India and
other former parts of the British Empire
became independent was that anything
which was which remained or had been
British territory was mi5 and anything
which had never been part of the British
Empire was mi6 or sis which was all
pretty crazy because the idea that you
know in Africa neighboring independent
states would have different British
responsibilities so ever since the the
late 1960s it has been as I asked which
mi6 which has the the responsibility but
going through all the papers I don't
think anything surprised me more than
the response of newly independent parts
of the British Empire to maintaining a
connection particularly with mi5 so
here's just one example at the beginning
of the 1960's jomo kenyatta
the greatest independence leaders I
think everybody here knows in the
history of West Africa came over to
Britain to settle the final details and
Lancaster House of of Independence now
if anyone had any right to be and really
really personally angry with the British
authorities during such a negotiation it
was him he'd been accused quite wrongly
of being a member of Mau Mau he had been
locked up and so on and he insists on
going to mi5 headquarters this causes an
amount of trepidation but when he turns
up
so Roger Hollis the then head of
mi5 he simply says I've so much enjoyed
talking to your representative in
Nairobi and so as my a daughter and
would you kindly stay on I think that
may have had something to do with the
fact that he felt that he needed further
advice all over again grow dinga but
there we are anyway that is a shorter
the shortest answer I can give to a
question which deserves much longer one
no I didn't yes which is why the whole
of my side like to as announced at the
beginning will be on that subject it's
it's simply there wasn't time to include
it but I will give just one one link
between what I say I plan to say then
and what I've been saying today which I
don't think preempt and that is the
importance of a long view the Russians
have actually even though their
interpretation of past intelligence is
not something that I agree with
they have been far better at taking a
long view than we have done in the the
official history well the authorized
history written by me as official
historian of mi5 only goes back to the
Victorian era the official Russian
historian history of foreign
intelligence six volumes I disagree with
the interpretation but I agree with the
other timescale goes all the way back to
not merely that Ivan the Terrible be
beyond Ivan the Terrible
hi thank you for your talk so your last
slide there how do you see I wonder if
you can elaborate on how the role of
Technology well what it does of course
is to change online jobs change life but
there's no reason to believe is there
that it's yet have the invent the impact
that the invention of printing had in
the 15th century
I mean comparing across several hundred
years is is pretty difficult but you can
see why the inability to come to terms
with new methods of IT can bring what a
previously being a great part down to
the also-rans and this is after all what
happens to the Ottoman Empire you know
not simply by view but Ataturk said
exactly the same about them when he gave
a long view in the in the end of 20th
century so they want him access to the
Internet does those countries who tried
to limit themselves limit the access of
their citizens to it are condemning
themselves to a degree of backwardness
which makes someone kind of comparison I
mean history never completely repeats
itself but as people who say they it
rhymes so you know Chinese universities
research on contemporary on the
contemporary world relaxed the most
basic credibility because of the
obstacles that put which in some ways
are reminiscent of the Ottomans to the
the study of sources which are available
to all the all the rest of us and as I'm
saying I really really enjoyed going to
lecture at Peking
University with the contradiction
between these people is understanding of
Sansa you know beat any lecture audience
that we expect to find in Britain when
talking about them classical learning
and international relations there today
just hit a point beyond which it could
not develop any other questions the
current American president has been
somewhat ambivalent in his relationship
with the intelligence agencies you talk
with deep state and so on
Sarita historical precedent for that
kind of relationship between the rules
our intelligence agencies yes that is
the subject of my lecture tomorrow oh no
no no not the the entire the entire
subject but we sort of take it for
granted that heads of government and
heads of state will sort of get on with
the intelligence agencies and when it
doesn't happen this is regarded as I
don't know something so bizarre how can
we take it in but their operative
previous examples are they're talking
about the particular individual having
scanned the last three or four thousand
years of human history I find it
difficult drawing exactly well any other
questions
all right then thank you professor
Andrew for a very very interesting
presentation I invite you all to join us
upstairs in the common room for a
reception
[Applause]
[Music]
you